it looks like kim kardashian is ready
for 2021.
a source tells et that the mom of four
is quote focusing on the new year
and a lot of amazing things that are
coming her way
this comes after et learned that kim has
considered divorce from her husband
kanye west
you know it's been a journey the source
adds that kim has tried everything she
can to make things work with kanye but
it's not working kim has held on to the
relationship in hopes of a change and
for the sake of the kids
but all signs are pointing to divorce
in the meantime kim has been keeping
busy she and the rest of the kardashian
jenners recently shot their final
episode of keeping up with the
kardashians
this is our last keeping up with the
kardashians miking
of life
don't cry don't cry you guys the last
miking ever
but this won't be the last we see of the
famous family on our screens
they've all signed an exclusive deal
with disney to create a new reality
series for hulu
hooray oh hooray on top of that a source
tells e.t that kim
is also quote focused on raising her
kids and making sure they're in a safe
stable environment i do want to make
sure that i have enough time for
everybody
because having kids is just there's no
way to describe it but it's a lot
that's like the best way i know how to
describe it